good afternoon and welcome to life
sciences conference on targeting the
oncogene you carry the initiation factor
4e at the Benton in the clinic I just
like to say that i'll be taking all
questions at the end so just you can
type them when you like but i'll be
answering them all at the end and if you
have any further questions or if you're
you're watching the recording my email
is on the bottom of this slide so you
can go ahead and email me any questions
that you might have so let me tell you a
little bit about the eukaryotic
translation initiation factor 4e which
I'm going to just nickname for you here
yeah a four-year overexpression leads to
transformation in cell culture and
animal models and also rescue cells from
a pathetic stimuli for e is elevated in
thirty percent of human cancers and its
overexpression installs um can cause and
as I said tumors and also for your
expressing cells have appeared to
develop an oncogene addiction to eif4e
providing a therapeutic window for
potentially targeting this protein as
you'll see later on in this talk yeah
f40 has elevated an approximately thirty
percent of human cancers these include
acute myeloid leukemia blast crisis
chronic myelogenous leukemia as as as
well as a broad array of different other
types of leukemias note that some
leukemias I'll have a very high
penetrance of high 4e such as head and
neck cancer whereas other where ninety
eight percent of heading neck cancer so
that elevated for ye whereas other
cancers like breast cancer diffraction
specific subtypes that have elevated 4e
now a basic question clearly is how does
yeah F where you become elevated and
there's a wide variety of ways this can
happen and I've only listed three here
but there's undoubtedly many more a
increased stability of for trna by
factor called Hur is one way that 40
levels become elevated in cancer gene
amplification is another way that 40
becomes elevated in cancer and an
increased transcription particularly
noting the NF Kappa B and C mcbath ways
for elevating eif4e levels and I just
like to note that a wide for that these
multiple pathways here can work together
so for instance we can see increased RNA
stability and increased transcription in
the same cells so yeah I just like to go
through what are the effects of the I
f4e many of you will be familiar with
them with 40 as a generalized
translation factor and I want to take a
moment to show you that yeah I for these
effects are specific for instance many
years ago in coffman at all we can see
using s35 Matheny that um eif4e um is
highly is causing s35 medaille not
causing global changes in protein
translation whereas we can look at
another picture where we can see that
eif 4e is um is actually a antisense
I'll goes to an Tyson salvo nucleotide
treatment to 4e does not lead to an
overall change in global translation but
yet it has a specific effect on trans
translation as shown by the studies of
Jeremy graph at all I'm just having a
minor technical issue with my slide deck
for a minute so just give me a second
while I try to get my duck to work again
but I think it's very important point
that for it's known that for E is
actually involved in only specific
effects in in translation and in and not
general effects
now the other thing that many of you
will be familiar with is the idea as I
said before that for you is a global
translation factor but it turns out that
40 also plays an important role in the
nucleus in the specific RNA export of a
subset of translation of subset of
transcripts and so what happens in in
this is that I'm still having a
tremendously hard time with my web
interface I apologize what happened what
happens with this is that that for II
can actually move subcellular
compartments so it's sometimes in the
nucleus and sometimes in the cytoplasm
as you can see here where we're looking
at for a movement through through mm the
embryonic stem cell embryonic stem cell
differentiation from embryonic stem cell
to macrophage and we can see here that
clearly um the that the clearly the
localization of 4e is completely altered
in in this case um and now the slide
deck is completely frozen and I don't
know what to do because I can't even
okay we'll see um sorry so we'll go to
the next slide where what you're seeing
here is that for E is thought to main
functions as you could tell from the
confocal microphone and in the cytoplasm
so in the cytoplasm for e um plays its
traditional role in translation and it
specifically targets the translation of
rnase that have complex five prime
untranslated regions and as you can see
from the earlier data I showed you not
all rnase
are having their translation modulated
by either for overexpression or by
antisense i'll go for e what we can see
here is the 40 crystal structure of four
E and we can see it by Bing the methyl
seven guanidine cap shown in yellow and
together it binds to the translation
machinery allowing engagement of
translation and this contributes to the
proliferation and a pathetic rescue
functions and thus oncogenic
transformation properties of eif4e such
rnase that are involved in this
particular process include genes such as
vascular endothelial growth factor in
oregon decarboxylase which have complex
x prime untranslated regions and allows
us to look at allows the specific
translation of these targets now this
side of the cytoplasmic side of the
equation many of you will already be
familiar with however for you as you saw
is also found in the nucleus and again
for you must bind the methyl 7 guanosine
cap structure in order to act in the RNA
export of specific rnas for you must
also interact with specific recognition
factors that bind a element called for z
element in the 3 prime utr of target
rnas which have a specific secondary
structure shown here these these target
protein these target transcripts have
their export elevated by 4e independent
of any effect that may occur also at the
translation level we estimate
approximately 700 transcripts are
controlled in this way some of these
transcripts like ODC are also
translation targets whereas other
targets such as cyclin d1 seem to be
mainly export targets and for instance
veg f is a translation only target in
order to be sensitive to for yet both
the export and translation levels you
must have a complex 5 prime utr and you
must have this 3
element in utr the 15 nucleotide for Z
shown you'll notice it for so in this
way or you can coordinate li regulate
transcripts involved the same
biochemical pathways such as liberation
and a frittata cres q and also note that
both the nuclear and cytoplasmic
functions of 4e requires ability to bind
the five prime methyl 710 Z cap
structure so if we look at at the
evidence supporting up and RNA export
function for you I'm showing you three
specific sets of evidence first we can
take the nuclear fraction of cells and
do an RNA and need a precipitation or
what I'll call a rip and we can look at
specific rnase using quantitative PCR
such as cyclin d1 which is a 40 export
target and gas CH which is our negative
control and if we I p4e we can clearly
see that in cells treat in the rip that
we have a substantial enrichment of
cyclin d1 44 e if we treat these same
rips with m7 G PPG an analog of for ease
normal ligands we can clearly see that
that we've lost the interaction proving
its cap dependence and if we use a
negative control that is not a
competitor we don't have an effect so
here you can quite clearly see cyclin d1
is a target and in green you can quite
clearly see the gap th is not a target
indicating this is specific and
importantly in the IgG controls we see
no amino precipitation now if we take
ourselves and fractionate them into the
cytoplasmic and nuclear fractions and
look at the ratio of cytoplasmic to
nuclear cyclin d1 RNA for instance we
can see in for y over expressing cells
we substantially increase the export of
cyclin d1 and this permits an increase
in the expression of the cyclin d1
protein without having to change either
transcription or translation if we take
a mutant that is in active in promoting
translation but is active in promoting
export we can clearly see that we still
have a nice export phenotype
if we take a foreign use in capable of
binding the cap this phenotype is gone
again reinforcing the requirement for
the cab in the final panel we can see
that if we do cycling do if we do a an
rnai experiment and get rid of 4e that
in this case instead of looking at the
nuclear to cytoplasmic the cytoplasmic
to nuclear ratio I note that we're
looking at the inverse so we're looking
at the nuclear to cytoplasmic ratio and
you can clearly see that in this case
when we knock down for e we
substantially increase nuclear retention
so all this really supports the idea
that for you bind specific rnase in the
nucleus and promotes their export for
you let me show you something about
whether 40 is normally found in the
nuclei in in primary human specimens
we're going to focus today on m4 m5 AML
and blast crisis CML patients because we
know them to have highly elevated 4e and
as you can see here versus the normal
versus the AML specimens that 40 is very
much elevated in these cells and it's
highly enriched in the nuclei of these
cells so I remind you that these are
blood cells that have very fine small
cytoplasm and very large nuclei if we
look at a western blot wear pink is
normal and glue here are the primary
specimens you can clearly see the four E
and its RNA export target are highly
elevated in these specimens if we go on
we can look to see the total RNA levels
by northern blot and we can see between
the patients and the normal that we
don't have any alteration in cyclin d1
levels indicating that the increase at
the protein level is not transcriptional
and if we look at an assay to look at
the nuclear to cytoplasmic fraction
again using northern blot in this case
and we compare a normal to leukemias
we can clearly see that in leukemias we
have an increase in cyclin d1 RNA export
whereas our negative control gap th is
unchanged so this indicates that for you
is highly elevated in in these primary
AML specimens it's highly enriched in
the nucleus and this fraction is active
and able to increase the export of one
of its targets like Lindsay 1 RNA and I
should say that we've tested many other
targets this is not special to cyclin b1
so if we look at the next question how
does yet for you promote RNA export so
how does this work so I'm only going to
show you one summary slide on how this
works this is really to do with partly
to do with the ability of 4e to change
the nuclear pore complex so what we can
see here is that you have in purple the
what we call the four ZN p which is
eif4e bound to the its target for z
containing RNA and it also binds other
cofactors and instead of traditional RNA
export for his exported via creme the
cream one exporter in a ram GTP
dependent way what happens when you
overexpress 4e is rather striking we see
a massive change in the structure of the
nuclear pore complex specifically you
can see that the major cytoplasmic face
where the aeroshell is shown now is made
up of cytoplasmic fibrillar mille cells
but these Federal's are almost
completely gone because the main
constituent of these pebbles round 2 p2
has been substantially lowered by 40
overexpression we also see
mislocalization of other components of
the cytoplasmic face of the nuclear pore
in these particular cells and indeed if
we look at primary AML specimens we see
ram PP 2 levels are severely reduced in
the AML specimens relative to the normal
controls indicating that although these
experiments are mainly derived from unit
cell lines they are a scope applicable
to human disease
in particular what we see here is that
eif 40 is most likely promoting cargo
release or the release of its RNA aren't
p into the cytoplasm by eliminating the
steric hindrance of the presence of ram
vp2 in these 4 y over expressing styles
this permits a more effective cargo
release release of the RNA into the
cytoplasm so it can then go on and be
translated and enhances recycling and
release of cargos so that the factors
that are important for export can now go
back more quickly to the nucleus and
allow further rounds of RNA export so
how do we clinically target eif4e in the
perspective particularly of acute
myeloid leukemia so we identified many
years ago almost 10 years ago in fact
that this small molecule well-known
antiviral drug ribavirin acts as a
competitive inhibitor of the I f4e what
I don't have time to show you in detail
but I'll show you a little bit is is on
the following list so ribavirin you we
will show you directly binds eif4e and
it directly binds in or near the
overlapping with the cat binding sites
ribavirin inhibits for you activity in
cell culture ribavirin for ii complexes
can be found in lifestyles using
tributed ribavirin ribavirin inhibits
for you activity in patients and primary
specimens and i'll show you our clinical
trial data and finally a loss of the
ragnar and tori interaction correlates
with clinical resistance so this is just
some data to show you the direct
interaction of four E and its ability to
compete for the cat binding site what
people do to look at whether for you
combine the cap or one of the many ways
is to bind cap onto a methyl seven cap
sepharose and what you see is that 40
sticks to the step rose as you would
expect and as you Aleut with cap it
comes off and and also if you take the
active metabolite of ribavirin rather
grand triphosphate known ears aren't
p we also see this washing off similarly
GTP and g PPG which are not competitive
inhibitors or fun or capable of binding
for e do not watch shop for you from a
sepharose beads whereas you can clearly
see our TP and cap do of course this is
using all purified protein and pasaste
and so put in these assays so of course
we want to know whether we can actually
see these complexes in live cells and
using either or using both experiments
separately using cross-linking IP or
straight straight IP with traded right
over and we can see that forty ip's
substantial amounts of created ribavirin
versus the IgG control indicating that
right a very binds 40 and living cells
again and other evidence to show the
ribavirin buys for you directly is
derived from mass spectrometry what we
can do here is we mix we had a mixture
of April VI f-4e ribavirin and GTP as a
negative control we only see two peaks
evo VI f-4e and the ribavirin eif4e
complexes indicating that by mass spec
ribavirin vines for a directly and we
see no peak for the GTP complex
indicating the GTP did not bind under
these conditions which is good as it was
our negative control we also have used
NMR to look at cap binding what r TP
binding and whether it binds in the cat
pocket and so what you're looking at
here is the enema the spectral changes
that occur in gif for EE upon NMR
binding happen in the cap binding site
and we also do see some changes in the
dorsal surface of the earth for you
which is a surface very important for
all its binding partners and similarly
cap also if the natural Maggie Natori
cap also causes similar changes on to
the dorsal surface we can see in these
NMR spectra wear red is a pony I f-4e
and blue is RT
he bound for you that we see substantial
perturbations in the NMR spectra again
supporting the idea that these are
direct binders and they're binding RTP
is binding directly in the cap binding
pocket and I know also that RTP does not
bind a cat finding new where the W 56 is
being mutated with alanine now whether
the effects are right over in which
because it's a small drug could have be
highly play atrophic you clearly have to
show that the effects that you observe
on growth for instance are due to the
presence of its effects on four E and so
what you see is an experiment by Wilson
Miller's labs philip peterson in
particular where breast cancer cells
were treated with aside RNA to scramble
controls or 24 e and then treated with
ribavirin and what's very notable is
that the scrambled controls you have a
nice dose-dependent effect on the
repression of growth of these cells in
the presence of ribavirin in SI for t
cells despite the fact that you still
have room to go you see no further
reduction in growth indicating that the
reduction in growth here is due to
Robbie Burns interaction with four E and
I should also like to note that we
clinically achieved well over 20 micro
motor 4e with no toxicity in patients
routinely so we worked on acute myeloid
leukemia because it has very poor
prognosis and as you saw earlier 40
levels were highly elevated and forty
was was very active in his RNA export
function which is the function that
we've been interested in studying so
just to go over what the statistics
currently are for acute myeloid leukemia
the majority of patients are over 60 um
the patients that don't receive
intensive chemotherapy have an average
four months survival and although the CI
rates are around forty to sixty five
percent eighty-five percent will relapse
and important importantly patients even
you see our median survival is still
only seven months so clearly we have a
long way to go to improve the clinical
outcome of this disorder and just to
drive that home there's the following
quote two points I'd like to make
currently management in AML and older
adults which is the majority of patients
is unsatisfactory I mean the standard of
care of a National Comprehensive Cancer
Network guidelines recommend clinical
trials is the first option for nearly
all patients with AML over at the age of
60 and it's also important to note that
the crisis in AML is quite well the
disease progression is quite rapid
patients who only receive palliative
care they're they're survivals measured
in days not weeks or months and so this
is very different than perhaps standard
chemotherapy is standard um solid tumor
cancers that many of you may be more
familiar with so we decided to target
yet for activity and inform five AML
patients using ribavirin and look to see
it we could target before activity and
whether we could have any clinical
responses and so this first trial was a
reverend monotherapy trial no other
chemotherapies were were permitted it
was a multicenter trial between to
montreal hospitals Oh Pete amazing off
rosemont and the Jewish general where
the trial is coordinated and one by
Steve dr. Surrey gasoline and also with
our collaborators in McMaster Cancer
Center in particular Brian Weber our
clinical responses are summarized here
12 out of 15 evaluable patients showed
clinical responses we had a complete
remission to partial remissions three
blasts responses which is the reduction
of the leukemic blast of leukemic tumor
load by 50% six stable diseases and
three patients that didn't respond we
also saw a regression of skin lesions
and one of the PR patients for which had
a leukemic a mechanic leukemia cutis
indicating that we could target outside
in the blood compartment all our
patients were very poor cited in
cytogenetics bar one and had
intermediate to adverse risk and
unfavorable molecular markers and all we
were refractory or relapsed so what we
can see here is very striking this is
the result of patient 11 who achieved a
complete remission you can see here the
highly enriched nuclear eif4e that was
characteristic of the primary AML
specimens we received from banks I
showed you earlier and what we also see
here is that 28 days when this patient
first achieved relapse with worldwide or
with a achieved remission with oral
ribavirin that 4e localizations changed
dramatically it looks much more like a
normal style and this correlates with
bone marrow smears here that are clearly
highly the pinna can hear the cells you
can see nice signs of differentiation so
this all indicated to us that ribavirin
could go to target eif4e activity and
that we can see clinical benefits so we
looked at length and width molecular
response obviously in clinical trials
you don't always have all the material
you would like so we looked at the
material we had and we saw very
strikingly that we were hitting 40
targets where ribavirin after 28 days in
the patients was causing reduction in
our 48 targets such as nbs1 and cyclin d
we also expected from our molecular
biology that 40 inhibition should lead
to decreases in phospho akt and we saw
that the other interesting and
unexpected thing that we saw was that
for II itself was lowered and we never
saw that in any of our cell line
experiments and it also show you later
we did substantial resistance
experiments where we grow where we grew
eight resistance tiles and ribavirin for
over 200 days and yet saw no change in
total 40 levels and so we believe that
this is actually a population selection
where the ribavirin is actually getting
most of the 4e sensitive cells and now
you're seeing you're seeing cells that
are not not for a sensitive I should say
that both um patient 6 and patient 10
achieved blast responses and so what
you're seeing here is not in difference
between normal and a tumorigenic what
you're seeing here is actually a
difference in the blast population
before and after treatment well we can
also see nicely is a reduction in RNA
export as you would
by both inhibition and lowering it for e
where we're looking here at this
particular target nbs1 and at clinical
response you can see the patient had a
substantial lowering of her army export
activity so that sort of provided
support that we could target eif4e
activity with ribavirin in patients and
that this could correspond to clinical
response oh and I don't have time to
show you but is published in part in our
blood paper is that RNA and confocal
analysis showed that not non-responders
had no effect on 40 activity and when I
go through the resistance section at the
end some of the reasons that that is
true will be discussed so this is
showing you one of the things that
happens at relapse this is a patient who
achieved a blast response and read our
bone marrow blast percentages and in
blue are peripheral blood of responses
so you can see when the patient here at
56 days had her best response we had a
massive relocalization of 4e very
similar to what you saw in for the
patient I first showed you with the
complete remission when you compare that
to the blue for treated cells
unfortunately what we note is that it
relax here where we have blasts climbing
very high we also see a nuclear the
entry of 4e indicating that probably
we're no longer able to target for you
and I'll show you that's true that the
rug burn is getting chemically modified
and no longer binds for you to relapse
patients so what to do next well
obviously we want to understand the
molecular underpinnings of drug
resistance and we would want to try a
traditional approach of combining a
chemotherapy with our targeted agent to
see if we can improve the proof duration
and frequency of response we chose
low-dose Sarah seed for this combination
because of the because there's been some
evidence that first of all this drug as
well tell about tolerated in the over 60
population versus high-dose chemotherapy
and and secondly some evidence that
low-dose heresy by itself could have
some single
activity so we carried out a trial phase
one trial which we just completed and we
did run into number of PK issues but
what like I'd like to show you is some
of the results we got for the patients
who had reasonable amounts of PK given
the number of reasonable lots of
ribavirin in their plasma given the
dosages that they were getting we see
that this number should be room for a
response really needs to be about 20
micro molar or more we had 10 patients
that fell into this group so far of
these we had to complete remissions so
one of which was very long lasting this
patient responded for two years and that
was particularly satisfying because she
had a AML that was secondary to her
breast cancer chemotherapy and we had
another patient but a CR responding for
nine months we also had a patient who
had a partial remission for four months
but had a dose-limiting toxicity and had
to come off of ribavirin so although he
was still clinically responding he had
to come up trial we had to blast
responses for four months and we had
four stable diseases and unfortunately
we had a progressive disease so one nice
thing that we can see is the molecular
targeting and particularly at the conf
local level which allows us to measure
even at response when you have very few
cells to measure anything for that we
could see for EV localization continues
to correlate well with with the clinical
responses so what you're seeing up here
is blast is the percent of bone marrow
blasts in patient one who was the one
who achieved a response for two years
dropping steadily over the start of her
treatment and in the bottom we can
clearly see a 40 come focal micrographs
and where you see the drops really
starting to happen we start to see
really nice relocalization of 4e I
unfortunately don't have to show you
here but at at relapse of 24 months this
patient had a had reentry of 48 very
much that the way I showed you for the
previous patient with the blast response
so obviously one of the key things that
we would like to understand is the basis
of ribavirin resistance because perhaps
that would allow us to to get our
patients to respond for longer or for
patients that are suffering from primary
resistance to respond at all so here is
just showing you um some of the
chemistry of ribavirin entry into the
cell so here is ribavirin in order to
enter right over it has to go through
the ante 1 transporter to cross into the
cell and then ribavirin has a very
important step where it has to be
phosphorylated to become rather guard
monophosphate and this is through
adenosine kinase and then a multiple
kinases can act for the ultimate
conversion of ribavirin to write over
and tri phosphate which is active form
what we found when we made cell lines is
that many of the cell lines had a loss
of adenosine kinase and this was a major
reason at least in cell lines for
ribavirin resistance in what we refer to
type 1 ribavirin resistance which is
rather an resistance where we see a net
uptake impairment as measured by treaty
ated rather burn uptake studies so
mutation of this and also the nucleotide
ups I transporter really prevent the net
uptake of ribavirin so we went and we
look to see how often this kind of
resistance could potentially help us
understand how how patients were
becoming resistance we looked at one of
the the CR patients from a Moroccan
monotherapy trial and a patient that
never responded in the ribavirin
monotherapy trial and we used real-time
pcr during during the course of
treatment before treatment during
response and treatment and what you can
see for instance a patient 11 is that
this particular individual had a very
large drop in ATK levels as you can see
here and also in the transporter itself
indicating that this patient was
probably resistant because no ribavirin
was actually entering cells patient 9 is
a patient who never had a molecular or
clinical response and what's interesting
here in dark blue is
adk levels and in blue and a pink are
before treatment in that 28 days for
this patient and this non-responding
patient you can clearly see how about
fivefold less ATK than a normal person
strongly suggesting that this patient
also is resistant because I ribavirin
really never enter the cells now we have
a second type of resistance that we
refer to as type 2 and this is distinct
in that you have normal drug uptake but
you have a loss of the eif4e ribavirin
interaction and no detectable mutation
and AF foreign or other changes in eif4e
levels so let me show you the four year
at aberrant interaction theta so what we
have here is three cell lines a parental
cell line our type 2 resistance cell
line and our type 1 resistance salad the
type 1 resistance cell line is the one
with the ADK mutations no ribavirin is
taken up as you can see here in pink and
thus there is no eif4e right under and
immunoprecipitation however you can see
here with the type to resistant cells is
that ribavirin uptake is normal it's
indistinguishable from the parental
cells however there's no return for you
interaction in these cells relative to
the parental controls so we obviously
wanted to know why that was and Ollie I
f-4e activity was was normal there
didn't seem to the cells the type to
resistant cells were still sensitive to
SI our needs for e indicating that for a
sensitivity was intact for you bound the
captain eats dating extent and in
general was completely normal me cells
so we wondered what causes this type 2
resistance and in order to address this
who use deep sequencing methods and we
observed a 17 fold increase in the sonic
hedgehog signaling pathway transcription
factor called lead one and and this this
elevation is specific to the type to
resistant cells as you can see here are
type 2 resistance cells have high green
one the cells that have the AEK
phenotype are the same as
controls the other things that we could
see why not follow on to show you is
that gleam on overexpression insensitive
cells is actually sufficient to impart
ribavirin resistance and also resistance
to other drugs as I'll show you liwen
rna-mediated knockdown led to reversion
of resistance and this led us to
investigate and I'll show you that the
lead one inhibitor that's recently being
approved by the FDA for metastatic basal
cell carcinoma known as GD c 0 4 49 or
visible jib reverse resistance in these
cells and we went on and checked
patients and a monotherapy and also in
our in our combination study and have
been able to show they have elevated lee
1 upon resistance relative to clinical
response so this is just showing you
some of our primary patients lesson here
you can see glee we won elevation of RNA
levels a for treatment during response
and end of treatment and this is a log
scale so you can clearly see that we
have substantial increases in leeuwen
RNA consistent with what we saw in deep
sequencing and we also see here but if
we look at complete a patient which into
complete remission at response versus
relapse that we have substantial
elevation in we won levels as you can
see by confocal microscopy we chose
confocal microscopy not Western blot
here is because a response we have so
few cells to work with about a hundred
thousand that there weren't really many
other options what we can also see is
that non responding patients also could
have have very elevated we won perhaps
suggesting your basis for why those
patients who have normal ATK and are you
get resistant to write a very upfront so
we went on to look at the ability of
Glee one to modulate the 4e ribavirin
interaction and again we use our treaty
ated ribavirin and you know
precipitation experiment here's the IgG
controls and what you can see here with
the four eip in either the flag vector
control cells in pink the sensitive
overexpressing Glee one or in blue the
type to resistant cells that I've
already shown me and what's striking is
simply Glee one over expression by
itself is sufficient to lose the
interaction relative to the vector
control cell lines so Glee one over
expression also in parts resistance to
ribavirin we can see the parental cells
at their ic50 relative to now the cells
overexpressing blue one or the
resistance sounds that were drive by
long-term growth in right over so how
could glee one be causing drug
resistance well our deep sequencing
studies also suggested that we look at
the ug Teague Carano transferase family
of enzymes which transfer sugar moieties
onto metabolites and xenobiotics and can
alter their activity in this way and so
what you're looking at here is a Western
bloc looking at other parental styles
the type 1 resistance elves have had an
impaired drug uptake or the type to
resistant cells again hi greed 1 and
high you GT 18 say that the ugtt won a
family shares a common but they have the
same molecular weight range and then
share the common carboxy terminus and
the antibody we're using here is a Panny
2 t1s body so we're seeing all the
different forms of you to do one
together so globally what this suggested
to us is that if you elevate me one this
causes an elevation of you GT 18 and
this will eventually need to form a
ribavirin that's being blue kurama dated
that can no longer bind for e and this
underpins our assistance just to show
you that you gt's and can also be
elevated in our patients like the glee
one was we can see a patient the
nonresponse non-responding patient again
they have very high green one sorry very
high you GT relative to a patient in
response and a patient in response
relative to end of treatment when they
relapse has an elevation of you GT 18
again indicating that the ug g 18 is
like 31 is being elevated that relapse
or
is elevated as causes primary resistance
we shall hear that you gt1 a levels
correlates with glee one for instance if
we s I agree one here you also have a
reduction in you GT with no condom in it
changing for e again if we overexpress
the booty one in these two flag cells
that you saw some of the biochemistry
already up you can see that you have a
substantial elevation of me one sort of
commiserate with the the same same level
of you GT 18 / expression as is observed
when you have the resistance cells
themselves so glee one out you GT one a
levels correlate with booty one
expression so obviously no it doesn't
mean but we the you GT has actually blue
grown a dated right over and so we used
mass spectrometry in combination of
highly hydrophilic chromatography to to
identify ribavirin glucuronides so if we
took either the type to resistance cells
or the parental cells and look to be
solid metabolites for instance Reverend
Ike fasting and in the resistance cells
we also saw the rabbit very McGraw died
and we can establish that it's a comprar
no David and the carboxy a mite of the
tri izle ring using the collision
induced fragmentation techniques of m
sms what you'll notice is that the same
p is not present in the parental cells
indicating that this is specific to the
resistant cells what we can see here is
asking the question well um if ribavirin
is glucuronidation does it indeed affect
the ability of for e to bind right over
to bind it and so in this experiment
we've taken purified eif4e GST and we've
taken purified pure ribavirin RTP GTP
and we purified rather very good girl
died and what we can see clearly is that
the in this competition assay is that
for a binds ribavirin in the presence of
for blank but with it can be easily
competed by either ribavirin or or RT RT
p but is not competed by the negative
control gtp and is not complete competed
for in this tributed ribavirin sa
byrider very blue quran ID and
importantly GST it's not finding Trinity
driver and by itself so what we can say
from these studies is that the eif 40 x
and ribavirin not the riders very good
gharana so obviously we'd like to
establish pharmacological means to
control this and what what you're seeing
here is just looking to see whether
edition of the glee one inhibitor GDC
could allow recent cessation and loss of
the glucuronide so here let's first look
at recent citiz a shin so in light blue
are the type to resistant cells and in
dark blue or the parental cells and what
we can see here is that if we add
ribavirin at the ic50 the parental cell
responds whereas the resistance cell
does not as expected given its own
resistance cell but if we add GC and
ribavirin together you have a nice
cooperative effect where the resistance
cells are now responding and I note the
GDC by itself does not have any marked
effect on either the resistant or the or
the parental cells so GDC is one
inhibitor it inhibits by binding extra
cellular receptor of 451 signaling
smoothened we also wanted to take a
second approach to check that we saw the
same effects so we used a drug at 61
which directly binds between you want
inhibitor and we see the same effect
where gap 61 by itself doesn't affect um
doesn't affect growth but can 61 in
combination with ribavirin affects both
um you can see both parental and the
resistance cells so does this
phonological inhibition correlate with
the with the chain with changes in blue
renovation so obviously we started
looking at levels of you GT 1a
mental cells versus the ten ourselves
and what you can see is when you add jdc
you substantially lower leeuwen levels
which has been previously established to
be part of the mechanism of GDC action
and this correlates with a reduction in
you GT 18 so this is a very clear
correlation and if we take these same
cells and we treat we check to see if
for you can bind the right over and use
our treaty ated right over an IP
technique you can see it in the DMSO
controls but the resistance cells don't
bind for for he's not fine Rider guard
and apprentice cells do however in the
cells that are being treated with GDC
now you've restored the ability of 40 to
bind ribavirin and if we look at the
mass spec data we see that in cells that
have been treated with the GDC inhibitor
we no longer see the glue on a date its
form which occurs at about 4 21 and we
see the main peak being rather and
diphosphate so this indicates that
pharmacological inhibition of greed one
represses you GT one and restores
ribavirin 4e enter for interaction by
eliminating the right over cooper anand
leave one overexpression alone
correlates with the formation of Rodger
gran gran I'd so if we take either side
of lee wuhn parental cells or the flag
control you can see that the glue karana
is only present in the cells that
overexpress CLE one and not in the cells
that are the prone lee express vector
and as you'd expect if you overexpress
31 you lose the ability of foraging
tracked radiated rather than once again
showing that the Reverend who granites
can be formed by we won over expression
and this is through jus GT 18
overexpression so because
glucuronidation is such a broad
metabolic effect on many drugs we ask
the question could we have a multidrug
resistance mechanism occurring and so we
looked at whether
new independent drug gravitation could
also impart era see resistance and I
remind you that era see is the
cornerstone of AML therapy and so could
have wide-ranging in sort of
implications what you can see in this
Sun in this graph is looking at either
cells treated with DMSO or cells treated
with GDC and we have either the type to
resistance or the parental status and
what's clear here is that the resistance
cells obviously are resistant to also
receives fight the fact that resistance
cells had never seen era see in our
assay so that was interesting but what
was also very interesting it was that
only the combination not GDC alone but
the combination of jdc and era see or
rather burn a lot of drug sensitivity
once more and we saw a similar story for
Glee one over expression where again the
Glee one overexpression led to led to
two aresty as well as Robert very
resistance and finally if we do si tu si
gris-gris one we get a similar effect as
we do with GDC where once again SI ugly
one allows your specced raishin of aoc
sensitivity to our resistance cell line
finally we ask this question whether
this could be relevant in primary human
AML specimens that we obtained from
humble tissue bikes and what you're
seeing in here is that the blue colored
in this colony formation assay you can
see normals we have two different
normals and we also have three different
AML patients all of these AML patients
were diagnosed as m four and five AML
and in all cases they were drug
resistant they failed refractory relapse
specimens so very hard group to treat
and we see that when you treat these
cells with ribavirin or 209 a mole or a
RC you don't really see very much of an
effect um if you treat them with GDC
alone you don't see very much of an
effect but if you treat with either 209
a molar GDC or one micromolar GDC you
can clearly see that all of the AML
specimens
are sensitive in combination with
ribavirin or era C so this is very
interesting the GDC alone is not having
effect and I should note that all the
drug concentrations were using here are
easily clinically achievable GDC is
found even 10 20 micro molar and plasma
so this is these are physiologically
relevant concentrations so what this
shows us is that we want inhibition can
lead to responses in resistant primary
human AML specimens wasting in colony
both assays so what's our model well
this is what roughly our model for drug
resistance you have it starts off at
least in this form of drug resistance
with elevated lead one elevated green
one needs to elevated you GT which
allows you to have cougar on a dated
ribavirin form and this causes a loss of
the ribavirin for interaction which
allows enhanced growth and drug
resistance if we use any of the
strategies to inhibit Glee one either
rnai GDC 0 4 49 or miss much it or the
direct transcriptional binder of
transcription factor game 61 that
directly binds a Glee one protein all of
these will cause and a reduction in ug g
1 levels we no longer see the ribavirin
glucuronide we have restored targeting
of ribavirin to 4e and now we have
growth impairment so I'd like to just
conclude I hope hopefully today I've
shown you the targeting for e in faith
to monotherapy trial with Ryder grand
shows your missions and reasons for hope
hopefully I've shown you that 40 is an
interesting molecule and it works well
beyond what we think of normally in the
realm of translation I've also shown you
data from a second ribavirin trial which
is just finishing up showing that we
have nice responses with low-dose am a
RC and ribavirin I've shown you a new
mode of drug resistance vehicle you
independent glucuronidation and this is
certainly going to be an area that we
would like very much to
clinically with the hope that one day we
could combine 31 inhibitors with
glucuronidation to potentially inhibit
the connotation in patients and it also
brings a general question which i think
is that maybe we should be looking for
drug resistance earlier on in patients
and not just decide that our drugs are
failing after a month but perhaps they
worked for a bit and now the the cells
out smarted us and we need to figure out
on these resistance mechanisms work
before I take questions I just like to
acknowledge many of the people who did
the work I have to thank the clinical
trial research unit and all my clinical
colleagues particularly Surrey gasoline
and Wilson and Wilson Miller I have to
thank andreea James and see but the farm
science for all the help they did
because they helped us complete the mass
spec hidden was the main runner with the
resistance project I think she's done an
awesome job LaRon and Mike did the the
lovely NMR data you saw Billy aticle
Djokovic did a lot of the molecular
biology and the patient specimens and
also did beautiful work on understanding
how RNA export works and I like to thank
the rest of the lab patients and their
families for taking a chance with us and
of course all the the funding agencies
and I've been asked before I do
questions just to simply remind you that
you can get continuing education credits
if you go to this website so now I will
open up for questions and unfortunately
my site has completely won't let me look
at any of the questions so I will try to
figure out what to do to get the
questions okay I have I'm trying okay I
can only read unfortunately half the
question um I have two interrelated
questions um let's see if I can
unfortunately I I mean maybe Tracy you
can email me the question but my web
interfaces is completely messed up and
won't let me actually read the question
I think one questions as a therapeutic
potential of inhibiting 4e and we won in
other cancers and I think that's a
really cool idea right now we're trying
to get a lot of microarray data tma data
together to really try to look through
and see how often these cancers have
have green one and you GT at relapse
especially trying to find some gray data
that that has these guys happening
together anything with four equally one
and you GT but I think would be really
great potential targets for for Glee for
glee one mediated drug recent suit is a
shin so I don't know and unfortunately I
really can't manage to to look at the
other question the I know it says
questions in the chat box but my screen
is actually freezed into this half I can
only see a little bit of the question
questions I can't even see the chat box
at this point and I'm afraid if I reload
I'm going to actually go go off the air
but so I'm really sorry for that but in
in terms of whether for you can exist
extracellular lee in body fluid i'm not
really sure if anyone's looked at that
it's typically considered to be a
cellular protein i do note that
glucuronidation itself is is known not
only to cause increases in drug
solubility and that's the idea that
drugs can be more more readily more
readily exported but oftentimes drugs
activities simply changes and so the
glucuronidation causes can cause
proteins to bind
two new factors that they didn't bind
originally some very interesting older
work testosterone shows that sort of
thing so I think we should be sure to
remember the Google allegation doesn't
necessarily mean increased export just
means a change in function and in fact
it although it's typically defined as a
detoxification pathway it can actually
lead to to increase drug toxicity even
so I think with with that and my
inability to really read more than half
of the question because the screen froze
I'm really sorry please email me and
I'll be really happy to answer your
questions then thanks very much trade